aquí tenemos dos gráficas polares r
igual a 3 73 coseno de teta lo que
queremos encontrar es el área de esta
región en azul el área de traslape el
área de intersección de estos dos
círculos te invito a que le pongas pausa
al vídeo e intentes hacer esto bien
supongo que ya lo intentaste lo que es
interesante aquí es que claramente la
región está acotada por dos curvas
distintas y parece que las curvas
intersectan según vemos aquí a simple
vista cuando teta es igual a pi sobre 4
esto lo podemos verificar fácilmente
pues coseno de pi sobre 4 es igual a
seno de pi sobre 4 por lo que es cuando
el valor de estas curvas es el mismo así
es que las curvas coinciden en este
punto cuando te estás igual a pi sobre 4
si no fuera tan obvio tendríamos que
igualar estas ecuaciones y resolver para
theta pero aquí como mencionamos es algo
que podemos establecer a simple vista
así es que este es
y sobre 4 y la clave aquí es darse
cuenta que para teta entre 0 y pi sobre
4 la región está acotada por el círculo
rojo r igual a 3 seno de teta es esta
región que tenemos aquí mientras que
para teta entre y sobre 4 y pi medios la
región está acotada por el círculo negro
r igual a 3 coseno de teta por lo que
podemos dividir el área entre esas dos
regiones así es que para esta primera
región ya sabemos que el área va a estar
dada por un medio de la integral
definida desde cero hasta y cuartos de
de la curva que limite esa región que
está dada por tres seno dt está elevado
al cuadrado de teta más el área
comprendida por esta región que tenemos
aquí en azul la cual va a estar dada por
un medio de la integral definida
y cuartos hasta y medios de tres coseno
de teta elevado al cuadrado de teta que
es el área de esta región en azul y algo
que podemos apreciar de la gráfica es
que el valor de estas áreas va a ser el
mismo podemos ver que estos dos círculos
son simétricos alrededor de esta línea
cuya ecuación es tt igual a pi sobre 4
así es que lo que podemos hacer es
calcular el valor de una de estas dos
integrales para posteriormente al
multiplicarlo por 2 obtener el área de
toda la región y esto es algo que tú
puedes verificar posteriormente pero
aquí voy a usar esa simetría para
calcular el área total simplemente como
el doble de este valor es decir la
integral definida desde cero hasta
cuartos de aquí vuelva al cuadrado
tenemos 9 que es el cuadrado de 3 que
multiplica seno cuadrado de teta de teta
y esto lo podemos evaluar a mano lo
podemos evaluar con una calculadora
vamos a evaluarlo analíticamente para
esto sabemos que sea
de teta es igual a un medio que
multiplica a uno menos coseno de dos
tetas esta es una importante identidad
trigonométricas que nos hemos encontrado
varias veces en nuestras clases de
trigonometría déjame escribirla por acá
seno cuadrado de teta es igual a un
medio que multiplica a uno menos coseno
de dos tetas así es que si sustituimos
aquí esto obtenemos que es igual a
esto es igual a un medio que voy a sacar
del integral nos quedan 9 medios la
integral de cero a pi cuartos de uno
menos coseno de dos tetas de teta y esto
es igual a nueve medios
nueve medios que multiplica a veamos la
anti derivada de uno es teta y la anti
derivada de josé noé 2 teta
esto va a ser igual a menos menos seno
de 2 teta
menos seno de 2 te está dividido entre 2
déjame mejor escribirlo de la siguiente
manera déjame escribir lo mejor de la
siguiente manera esto de escribir como
menos un medio del seno de dos teta y
esto lo puedes calcular haciendo una
sustitución o adecuada pero podemos
verificar que la derivada de seno de 232
coseno de dos tetas y cuando
multiplicamos el 2 por menos un medio
obtenemos simplemente menos uno dándonos
menos 12 92 teta que tenemos ahí
lo vamos a evaluar entonces en nuestros
límites de integración lo vamos a
evaluar en pi cuartos y en cero y aquí
tenemos suerte pues al evaluar estos
términos en cero toda la expresión se
hace cero sólo necesitamos evaluar en pi
cuartos por lo que esto es igual a nueve
medios que multiplica a y cuartos menos
un medio un medio de seno de dos por ti'
cuartos seno de dos pop y cuartos es
seno de pi medios seno de pi medios y
aquí sabemos que ese nueve medios es
igual a uno así es que este término de
aquí se hace uno este término se hace
uno y esto va a ser igual esto va a ser
igual a nueve medios que multiplica a y
esto lo podemos escribir como pi cuartos
menos un medio o pi sobre cuatro menos
dos sobre cuatro y podemos dejarlo así o
podemos hacer la multiplicación por
nueve medios para obtener entonces que
esto es igual
9 y -18 9 menos 18 sobre 8 y así hemos
concluido